there are places where the serenity of
nature should be accompanied only by
quiet contemplation this isn't one of
those places from around the world that
come to Queenstown New Zealand ready to
make a leap of faith I'm so ready if
you've got an addiction to adrenaline
this is no place to kick the habit
New Zealand people have a very immediate
lifestyle a lot of the time and that's
what people can experience when they
come here
the jet though is just one of New
Zealand's adventure inventions
there's no propeller to the boat and
operate in just a few inches of water
were intended to navigate New Zealand's
shallow rivers but it turned out they
were just as effective scaring the
daylights out of customers paying for
the privilege
not that anyone's complaining it seems
that nearly every day another adventure
stored is created here now we quite
proudly cooldown so if you've been to
couple of the world there are so many
adventure to these to do you infantry
worked it out if you did one of every
type of activity you'd be here for sixty
days
all this is part of a tradition that
goes back to the birthplace of adventure
tourism in New Zealand the cow a low
bridge was the world's first commercial
bungee jumping it's tough enough to jump
at Cairo but at other sites in New
Zealand the drop is enough to make
adventure seem like the lunes or five
four three two the people who have to
really try hard to jump are the ones who
get the most out of it at least that's
the theory
but then after you've done it once
there's no need to chess in a land that
seems made for adventure
the only question may be what will they
think of next
whatever it is someone will be ready to
take the plunge